so they're asking us to find the least
common multiple of these two different
polynomials so the first one is 3 z to
the third minus 6 e squared minus 9z and
the second one is 7z to the fourth plus
21 z to the third plus 14 z squared now
if you're saying well what is the lead
you're familiar with least common
multiple of two numbers one way to think
about them is if i were to find say the
least common multiple between
i don't know
four
and six you literally could look at all
the multiples and see which ones are
which one is least so you go 4
8 12 16 so on and so forth you could do
the same thing for six you go 6
12 18
24 so on and so forth and you
immediately see that they do have
they'll actually have multiple common
multiples but the least of the common
multiples
you immediately see is going to be 12.
now another way to think about it is is
to actually factor these numbers out
we could view 4
you could view 4 as being
2 times 2 if you look at its prime
factorization and 6
is
2 times 3.
so you could say that the least common
multiple the lcm
of 4 and 6
is going to be or it's going to be equal
to what's going to have to have the
factors of both of them so it's going to
have to have two fours two times two
it's gonna have to have a two and a
three well we already have a two in fact
we have two of them so in order to be
divisible by three we have to be in
order to be divisible by 6 we have to
have 3 as one of the factors and so when
you look at it that way you say hey look
we have to contain all of the factors of
each of them we have to have at least
two twos
and we have to have at least one three
because the two twos take care of this
one two right over there and you see
that this is also going to be equal to
12. now when we think about it for
polynomials we're going to think about
it a little bit more it's it's
essentially the same idea but we're
going to think about a little bit more
with the second lens we're going to
think about the factors and say well the
least common multiple needs to contain
the factors of both but it shouldn't
contain more than that you can always
find a multiple of two polynomials by
just multiplying them but we don't want
to find just any multiple we want to
find the least common multiple so let's
factor each of them
so this first one
3z to the third minus 6z squared minus
9z
let's see immediately let's see all of
these terms are divisible by 3z so let's
factor out a 3z
so it's 3z
times
z squared if you factor out a 3z out of
that
see it's going to be -2 z if you factor
out a 3z out of that and then minus 3.
and notice if you were to distribute
this 3z back you would get exactly what
we have up here
and so let's see can we factor this
further can we think of two numbers that
if you multiply them we get negative 3
and if we add them we get negative 2 and
1 is going to be positive 1 is going to
be negative since their product is
negative so let's see it sounds like
negative 3 and positive 1. so we could
rewrite this as 3 z
times
plus 1
times z
minus 3.
i think i've factored this first this
first polynomial is about as much as i
can
1 times negative 3 is negative 3
1z
minus 3z is negative 2z so that looks
good so now let's factor
now let's factor this other character
over here this fourth degree polynomial
so every one of those terms look like
they're divisible by 7z squared so i
could write this as 7
z squared times
z squared when you factor out a 7z
squared here you're just left with z
squared
and then
plus
21 divided by 7 is 3
z to the third divided by z squared is z
and then plus 14 divided by 7 is 2 z
squared divided by z squared is 1. so
it's just going to be a 2 there
and so this is going to be the same
thing as 7 z squared and this can be
factored into let's see 2 times 1 is 2 2
plus 1 is 3. so
z
plus 1
times z
plus 2.
now let's think about the least common
multiple we've factored each of these
just the way that we when we did the
prime factorization for regular numbers
now we have factored this down to
to as simple expressions as as we will
find useful and so the least common
multiple of these two things has to
contain each of these factors so the
least common multiple has got to contain
a 3z
it's gotta contain
and let me let me expand it out a little
bit it's got to contain a three it's got
to contain a z
it's got to contain a z plus one
z
plus one it's i don't have to write a
little dot there since i'm it's got to
contain a z plus one
it's got to contain a z
minus 3.
let's see it's got to contain a 7. we do
not have a 7 here yet so we have to
include
we have to include a 7. so i'll put the
7 out front with the numbers it's got to
include a 7. it's got to include a z
squared well we only have a z right now
so let's throw in another z so i could
throw in another i could write 7 i could
put a z out front or i could just make
this a squared it still contains that z
but now we contain another z or
multiplying by another z to have z
squared
see we already have a z plus 1 in here
we need a z plus 2 as well
z plus 2 as well and there you have it
this is the least common multiple if i
were to write it all out in a neutral
color it's going to be 21
z squared times z plus 1
times z minus 3
times z
plus 2.
i say 2 and i write 6 z plus 2. and we
are all done
and i really want you to appreciate this
is the exact same thing we're doing when
we're doing or a very similar thing than
what we're doing when we're finding
least common multiples of regular
numbers we're looking at their factors
and in the case of numbers prime factors
and then we say okay the least common
multiple has to contain
each of has to has to be a superset has
to contain all of these but we don't
want to contain you know i can multiply
this times
times a hundred it's still going to be a
common multiple of these two but it's no
longer the least common multiple
likewise 12 is the least common multiple
of 4 and 6. if i just wanted a common
multiple i could multiply that times 100
1200 would also be a multiple of 4 and
6. but it wouldn't be the least common
multiple so we don't want to we don't
want to do that hopefully found that
interesting